ok de shippagan plusieurs crabiers se
prépare pour la saison de pêche
si les glaces partent rapidement elle
pourrait commencer à la mi avril
mais le courant n'a virus pourrait bien
venir jouer les trouble-fêtes
on ne sait pas pour but ce que vous
autres francs la tonne les règlements du
gros globe qu'est ce qui va se passer
réseau ce serait du jamais vu on craint
beaucoup les conséquences d'une
annulation de pêche au gros lapin roman
tu dises activités pêche ce qui nous
aurait dépêché ça va être toute une
région qui va
qui voyez-vous deal les pêcheurs met
quand même leur bateau à l'eau ils
veulent être prêts zone notre saison est
tellement restreint s'est hissé sa durée
coupe de semaine pierre sisser pas c'est
pas comme ça qu'on perd à l'année zéro
en réponse à ces appréhensions la
fédération régionale acadienne des
pêcheurs professionnels souhaitent les
rassurer pour jean lanteigne l'industrie
de la pêche doit continuer au même titre
que celle du poulet ou du boeuf
malgré la coved 19 ans réalise une chose
dans tout ça il faut quand même être au
sein de s'alimenter à lima le
gouvernement fédéral précise que la
pêche est au jour prévu mais on indique
que la situation évolue reste que le
noeud du problème se dessine dans les
usines de transformation
sans elle les produits ne peuvent pas
être transformés exportés dans ses
usines
des centaines de personnes travaillent
souvent près des unes des autres
sans changement ces conditions vont à
l'encontre des mesures de sécurité est
lié à la coved 19 des enjeux qui sont
les travailleurs du gène puis les hommes
de ben c'est pour drôle de la pêche au
crabe peut générer plus de 200 millions
de dollars dans la péninsule acadienne
ici l x villeneuve radio canada
shippagan